speaking of good-looking people um last
night I played with Eric coke on destiny
and it was an amazing night it was me
Eric coke Nick Rutherford ooh
Gardo coladas friend guard oh and my
friend my brother Frank Eric Griffin it
was so much fun and I want to propose
something to Tiger belly fans if you can
listen listen up guys
I need I will pay anyone listening $100
a piece to take me to the lighthouse in
Osiris and concerns of destiny if you
have n mo I'll give you 50 bucks up
front and then once I'm at a deposit
yeah and then when I'm actually at the
lighthouse I'll give you another 50 and
I will do that as many times as you want
I'm confused why do you have to ask
someone to do that it the problem is
that you do that and then you don't have
to filter through the emails me myself
you know me George is room and Gilbert
have to do it and we always get so many
and it's like how do they get our actual
hold of you are we supposed to tell you
yeah so what you tell me is this I think
this is a legit thing that they're
actually good and they will do it
because we need to set it up like 8
o'clock how are they supposed to prove
that they can in fact take you to the
lighthouse
that's why would he give you 50 bucks Oh
from no because there are gonna be a
bunch of people who are gonna be 50
bucks richer who aren't going to take
you to the lighthouse they're gonna say
they can take you and then they're gonna
like oh man sorry how about this no it's
a better idea once I'm at the lighthouse
I'll give you a hundred bucks hmm so
you're not gonna get paid unless I'm one
of the lighthouse but you have to know
that I'm kind of a public figure I'm not
gonna deceive your lie to you okay and
we're going to the lighthouse well this
is a verbal contract right now it's a
verbal agreement you saying out loud
that I will pay you a hundred bucks is
legally binding I don't know if it's the
is it it is because I say it is as long
as you understand about the hahaha
[Laughter]
I know but to me that's how you sound
the filter you
[Music]